un comienzo accidentado en esta primera
etapa del tour de francia etapa entre
bajas y donde no primera caída a 45 km
de la llegada cuando tony martin a la
alemán de yumbo misma se estrelló contra
la pancarta de alguien que estaba al
borde de la carretera y luego a 8
kilómetros de la llegada una segunda
caída masiva christopher froome estuvo
entre las víctimas pero no se hizo mayor
daño finalmente la etapa fue para el
francés william a la philippe el campeón
mundial de ruta uno de los favoritos de
todas maneras a llevarse esta etapa que
bueno a partir de hoy se viste con ese
maillot amarillo sexta vez que gana una
etapa en las cinco participaciones de el
francés en la compu los favoritos como
taddei ponga char quien está defendiendo
su título conseguido el año pasado así
como primos orobitg no perdieron tiempo
mañana otra etapa bastante difícil que
será entre perros de aquí
el bogotano ese muro de bretaña que
tendrán que ascender dos veces es un
ascenso de dos kilómetros a 6.9 por
ciento 183 km